c'est face à des bancs vides que le
recteur du sanctuaire de lourdes a
célébré sa messe samedi
pas de célébration de culte ni d'accès
aux piscines pour les fidèles
fermé depuis deux mois le sanctuaire
vient enfin de rouvrir ses portes à
cause de la fermeture du lieu depuis le
17 mars
plusieurs millions d'euros de pertes
sont prévus d'ici la fin de l'année
je vois l'avenir avec inquiétude parce
qu'effectivement la situation économique
de lourdes et complexes à l'image de ce
qu'est la situation du bassin lourdais
en l'absence de pèlerins pendant deux
mois l'absence de pèlerinage jusqu'à la
fin juillet sans doute l'a entraîné il
serait certainement une perte de l'ordre
de 8 millions d'euros pour l'ensemble du
sanctuaire et je vois aussi l'avenir
avec confiance parce que je sais que la
générosité des pèlerins n'a jamais fait
défaut sans tuer dans le passé toujours
lorsqu'il ya une difficulté
les pèlerins se sont manifestés pour
faire en sorte que ce sanctuaire
puissent venir puissent vivre et
aujourd'hui je je suis confiant je suis
joyeux d'ouvrir et je lance cet appel
avec sincérité avec humilité mais déjà
avec reconnaissance et des lourdes à se
remettre et des lourdes à préparer
l'avenir pour assurer la sécurité
sanitaire des pèlerins des malades des
mesures strictes ont été prises
le but est d'éviter toute propagation du
virus dans ce lieu habitué à accueillir
chaque année des centaines de milliers
de pèlerins
et pour cela le port du masque est
obligatoire et le marquage au sol doit
être respectée
[Musique]
enfin on peut sortir de chez nous attend
km et on est à 94 km d'ici
moi je suis venu une fois moins
tous les ans tu as en tant que
hospitalière et ses environs en tendant
à mes enfants
c'est beau de venir
et voilà que c'est aujourd'hui
dire merci à la
hier je me
m
on a fait couler
et depuis il
quand on voit tout évident alors que
c'est un endroit où il ya il ya l'amitié
il ya vraiment des choses qu'on ne voit
pas ailleurs
c'est à dire qu'on soit jeune âgé ou
pour
bourriche on est tous à la même enseigne
on se parle c'est un enfant on se parle
bien et puis couper tout ça énorme
les visiteurs ne rend que 10 par dix
dans le sanctuaire où des bénévoles
veillent au respect des distances de
sécurité des gestes barrières
si l'on sentait de nouveau ouverte de
14h à 18h la reprise des célébrations
publiques n'a pas encore été décidée par
les autorités
[Musique]